david can i just uh we've got apologies
from councillor wright
um as well he was intending to um come
tonight but he's been unavoidably
determined that's fine okay
right so we'll start start the meeting
now and uh firstly i'd like to
welcome you all to the meeting that
means the
members of scrutiny committee uh the
council officers
executive members uh and our guests who
are here
tonight i'm for those who don't know
i'm councillor david acton and i'm chair
of the scrutiny committee
and just to remind everyone who's in
attendance this meeting is being
streamed
live and i asked those that are
not speaking to mute their mics and
those wishing to speak during our
discussions
uh i asked them to
put a message in the chat room
if they wish to speak
[Music]
i've had a request to change the order
of the agenda so that
item five and item six
change around so that trafford economic
reset
recovery item will now come before
the acm uh cladding item
this is to accommodate uh the speaker's
requests um
so um we'll go on to the
agenda proper and the first item is a
attendance and uh and apologies
uh we we have had an apology for
councillor rose
thompson and i think dr
councillor dr barclay
says that she will arrive at 7 30
because she's working i think
item two um declarations of interest if
there's any
uh agenda items that you have of
declarations of
interest could you speak of now
i'll take that as i know um
item three and it's questions from the
public
um
we do have one question and the
questioner
is not present tonight but his question
relate to the ac
acm cladding agenda therefore
i will lead that question
to that item and i'll read that out
okay item four
the minutes can we agree those
somebody move them yeah okay
it's agreed so item five
is a trafford economic reset
and recovery plan
and i think members will
know that trafford economic
reset recovery plan has been agreed
in the council and we have
here with us tonight a representative
from
bruntwood chris roberts
and we have i think
uh enterprise u um which is an
organization
um uh with michael air
and hillary uh
qatar league and we have
a representative from um
financial wellness and that's
deborah weir and we have also
richard rowe who is a director of place
and
uh the executive member uh councillor
mike freeman uh and i think
the the reason why we've invited uh
those is that um you know any
recovery plan it we will
we will need as much help as we can from
uh different organizations and
businesses
in trafford so that we all work together
to
recover from this pandemic both
economically and socially um
so it i'm really pleased that um
you know we've got representatives from
those bodies that
i've just alluded to
so can i just ask richard if he wants to
stay a few words before we
um before our guests maybe introduce a
guest
[Music]
uh thank you david yeah i think uh you
summarized most of what i was going to
say so i thought scrutiny asked
for this session on the back of a
presentation that
adrian gave at last uh scrutiny
committee on
our on our economic recovery plan and a
report that we then took
through the council executive uh
following that to set out the economic
recovery plan in the context of
the broader recovery plan post covered
the request from um scrutiny that
obviously you'd heard from officers and
the work that
we had done with uh partners but wanted
to get a feel i think from
some of the industry uh bodies
um to a little bit more from them their
perspective
on the trafford economy but and also
more broadly
um what economic recovery in trafford
could look like
in a post-brexit post uh
covered pandemic uh world
um as we head out of hopefully uh on the
road map out of
lockdown through the rest of this month
into april and heading towards
june so we've engaged with a number of
businesses so we think we'll
all give a slightly different
perspective
uh with a swim with the town center
focus financial focus a micro business
entrepreneurial focus to give
a different feel to just come along and
give their
their view and maybe take a few
questions from
the scrutiny committee we are obviously
as as an
authority very open actively work with
business partners through the trafford
partnership through the inclusive uh
economy board and through another range
of informal and formal partnerships that
we
that we have um constantly trying to
use our own analysis our own data but
test that against the business
perspective and look at building those
very positive
relationships with both existing
businesses and with new businesses that
we want to attract and
attract into we've got a number of key
assets that we've talked about
um previously in the in the a range of
businesses
operating in we think that gives us a
fantastic opportunity a really strong
base and economic base from which to
build and come out of
the economic challenge that
corvid has provided as long as the
alongside the
the significant public health challenge
obviously
and some of the challenges that has
identified within the within
the local community so on that note i'm
not sure who
is lined up to go um first
i think is it christ in ireland over two
if it is i'll land over to chris
roberts from bruntwood who members will
be aware we have
a joint venture or three joint ventures
technically with bruntwood
um but they have a well-established
business base within greater manchester
and within
trafford and they've been working here a
long time before we entered into the
joint venture which is part of the
reason why they are
we're our joint venture partner
chris are you there i am hi
well firstly thank you uh very much for
having me
um chris roberts uh chief development
officer uh
bruntwood um i'd probably like to start
just by giving you a quick overview of
i mean some of you probably know a bit
about us of who we are and what we're
about
and i don't really mean about the sort
of the physical bit around the property
but what drives us and what motivates us
because
hopefully um from that sort of position
you'll understand
why we were really attracted with
working with trafford
and why um you know why why we were
really keen to be sort of
partnering and stakeholders in the area
so broome was a family-owned business it
was it was founded by mike oglesby
uh over 40 years ago um unfortunately uh
mike passed um about 18 uh 15 months ago
um he was a a you know i'm slightly
biased because he employed me when i was
21
but he was um an amazing sort of
inspiration for a lot of people
including me and and gave me a lot of
direction in life
the business is now run by chris um his
son
and kate his sister with a
an effective shareholder board who sit
around them and provide support and i
i'm i'm one of them
so broom with his business i think
firstly
um you know what's our purpose well our
purpose is we want to help contribute
creating thriving regional cities
um and by regional cities we mean cities
predominantly in the north
um and it's fair to say that our sort of
our founding
place of birth was greater manchester um
our biggest investment
portfolio is greater manchester um and
it's very close to the heart of the
business and always and always will be
our headquarters
um are going great to manchester as well
as the
as the majority of our assets um and
what do we mean by thriving cities well
in our world thriving cities means how
can we help contribute to
um social mobility better health care
outcomes
um innovation the sustainability agenda
increasingly becoming part of the part
of our sort of remit and our aims
um and general sort of skills and
improved inclusivity
um across the piece um and
and why do we do that partly because
it's the right thing to do and partly
because we just genuinely believe if you
get that right
the place is better the place is better
then communities and business thrive
your business and communities thrive
then as a stakeholder in those
businesses and communities we thrive
and at the heart of it we're a long-term
business um
we we're not a trader developer
occasionally we do
but the core part of our business is
investing for the long term
um and that means making sure and
helping support that the places we
invest in are successful
so you know we've supported that through
very key strategic partnerships with for
example manchester foundation hospital
trust where they're
uh where their commercial partner and
working closely on our with them on on
various initiatives at the moment all
over greater manchester
um in north manchester and the
regeneration of the manchester general
hospital
their central campus um and starting to
look at
with insurers well i'm aware they've
also got a hospital in
in trafford um and also then just
through partnering with other good local
charity organizations as well
um we've got a the the oakless family
who still own the whole business i've
got a charitable trust called the
oct uh short and snappy for oak speed
challenge
terrorist double trust um and as a
combined organization we give
uh 10 of our profits um to good causes
but more importantly
we give a lot of our employees time
so i sort of give that preamble because
it then leads on to
what's our um what what's our vision
and our vision as i say is to create
better places um
and to take and deliver all of those all
of those outcomes that we've talked
about before
we're not stupid we know that we're not
health organization but we know we can
provide commercial support
and charitable support into into those
organizations to help them function
better
and as with other other skills based
um charities i suppose that sort of
setting really
um is by you know working with trafford
and working in traffic where we just
felt very comfortable
um we've got a leadership who've got a
really clear
um vision of where and what they where
they want to go
um richard can cover his um his modesty
now they've got officers who are
motivated
and really want to help work and deliver
on the aims and the vision of the
of the leadership um and you've got all
of the other fundamentals
which um yeah appeal to us
you know you've got fundamentally um
strong
connectivity around transport you've got
you know a a good education system
i mean areas where obviously there's
there's areas where that can be improved
particularly around skilled uh
new training and new skills development
um and actually that led us into our
first
uh initiative with with uh with traffic
where we got very excited about the
opportunity of something very different
on the skills horizon with ua 92
um at the case site renamed luminar
um luminar village so
you know you're in grecia manchester as
well which is our uh our
our our sort of home patch um
you know strong leadership clear vision
of where you want to go
great transport connectivity strong
skills base already which
as everywhere can be improved and worked
on um
and the desire to move forward so all
those fundamentals were there um
[Music]
and you know we thought we could really
work closely with with with people who
were who we were engaging with
um and i suppose
you know you know the the the question
then is well what what
that was the world um when we entered
into this partnership which was
pre-brexit um
where it wasn't pre-brexit it was
pre-brexit officially happening
um it was definitely pre-covered
um i don't and i think you would be
naive to say that that's not
particularly the latter and my my view
is almost
that the former has been made
so small in terms of impact compared to
what the impact of the latter is
that it's almost been usurped um
and hopefully we're going to use pulling
together around um that the rebuild and
kobe is a way of mending many bridges as
well
but certainly the latter i think you'd
be naive not to believe and not to think
that it's going to create some
reasonably interesting structural
changes
um our view and um
and it was our view prior to cove it was
the
um and this was really around where
greater manchester was moving in terms
of its growth
in terms of its um increasing population
it's intriguing
it's increasing based skills um
its attractiveness to him with
investment um
which is disproportionately probably be
being in in the center of manchester
city center
but increasingly you will start to see
people looking out outside of those
areas
um it's strong track record in terms of
startups
and innovation it's strong academic
base and research base we were starting
to see the growth of
greater manchester anyway and the only
way that was sustainable
was for the strong uh towns in greater
manchester
to start to take up some of the slack
and actually provide answers that quite
frankly this city centre
can't provide and that's not to say the
city centre's not
been a fabulous um in many cases not all
but
been a fabulous sort of evolution over
the last 27 years
um but he can't provide all the answers
the greater manchester needs to
continue to grow economically and
socially
so we were already in that place and as
i say you were ticking all those boxes
anyway around education
skills connectivity um
sorry one second apologies
i think um kobe is probably only
heightened that
i think you're going to see a change in
in behaviors i think
um the people are going to want to
uh work more locally and shop more
locally
um i think they'll that you
you will see that there will be these
look
these strong particularly strong
regional towns and clusters
i think you will see um we'll see more
growth there i think you'll see a
service-led leisure retail sector that
provides
for more local uh people more
immunity-based people as people dwell
longer
um uh and i think the city center
will absolutely bounce back as well
because ultimately
um you only need to look at the type of
inward investment
and the jobs that are coming here or
companies that are growing here already
that are there to fill the space
um offices will change in terms of what
they look like
but offices have always changed um you
know when i
you know i first started you know people
occupied space reasonably
undensely then it went to a very dense
product again
and hot desking i think you're gonna
start to see that people are going to be
thinking
um well actually if i'm in the office um
i want to know perhaps some hot desk
because i'm only in two or three days a
week
but i'm now going to want more space
when i'm in there because actually i'm i
don't want to be an environment where i
feel like a sardine anymore
um i think that certain things that home
working can't do
so homeworking can't train the next
generation of graduates or kids leaving
school
they learn that by being in an office
environment or any workplace
environment following mentoring and
shadowing people
so i think it's probably really easy for
people who sort of
middle managers um who've reached a
certain level
um to to go i can work from home
but they can't because part of that
their role is training up the next
generation
and you can't do that from your lounge i
think it's also easy to say you've got a
garden and a spare bedroom
um you know i'm sat here guilty as
charged you go
working for him is quite nice um
that completely forgets you know a raft
of the of people in the workplace aged
sort of 18 through to i know early 30s
who are living in apartments or limited
space
or with young families um trying to do
homeschooling
and so again i think there's you know i
think um
that there are the people will still
want to use the office
and also basically we're social
creatures um and we thrive
um we innovate when we're with other
people where we're bouncing ideas
it is that sort of classic conversation
and bumping into somebody about the
coffee machine
chatting about something and then making
that connection and everything else
and that's where that's where best
practice and innovation and development
happens
so i think that the town centres will
continue
to grow i think will grow because
greater manchester is growing i think
they'll grow because actually they work
better
for certain types of business and um and
certain types of employer
employee um i think the ones that are
particularly well connected in terms of
public transport
will be able and we'll be able to
exploit that um
more and more grow quicker i think the
city centre will continue to grow
and we will continue to redefine the
boundaries of what we mean
by the city centre because we're going
to continue to see that inward
investment
and growth because
you know employers follow talent and
we've still got one of the largest
talent-based student populations um in
in europe in fact in europe um you know
with
75 000 you know degree educated students
and
25 odd thousands uh graduate students
coming out the universities each year
i think the big challenge is going to be
um for manchester's continued growth not
that not that research office center
digital tech sector
he's going to be training up that next
that other type of talent
the technicians um and as we start to
look at
um he's all very well inventing the drug
or inventing the technology i think
we're going to want to start to see and
we will need to see we're seeing it
through the local strategy and
the gm strategy the need to also start
making and manufacturing that
but this is not the old-fashioned sort
of manufacturing these are high skilled
jobs
and so i think there's a as a big role
at gm level where we need to play to see
that
that skill level being developed and
that talent pool being developed there
to be able to start production and uh
you know the creation of these products
but if we can get that right um you know
i'd remain
hugely positive for greater manchester
um
and specifically in the context of
trafford um
you know um absolutely i see you at the
forefront
of where gm um is he's going to go
because
we we we've never once since we entered
into the partnership you questioned
whether we did the right thing
i think our certainty that we did the
right thing has only got stronger as as
each sort of
month has passed and i'll show
you now i've talked too long no no
thanks very much for that chris
it was it was um very very helpful in
indeed and i think the perspective
um for the future and you presented that
really well because i think there are
you know huge
uh challenges but um huge
opportunities and i think that that's
what you've
portrayed and manufacturing is one of
those i think
and new ways of working
and shopping will be different i assume
uh
although those changes to online
shopping
was started a long time ago but it's
ramped up again hasn't it and
and you know the office spaces and all
of those kind of things things that
you know you you'll know a lot about and
hold
so everything will be different um i
want to bring the other
speakers in now before we sort of open
it up
to to sort of questions um
um richard who who who's
gonna go next did it have we got a
running order
[Music]
uh i'm not sure we have got a running
order i wonder if we go to
uh uh deborah abraham
yeah well
wellness yeah deborah are you
are you there i think you've got a
presentation haven't you as well
i have yes i think alexander's got that
too to
hopefully do that
okay can everybody see those slides
yeah we can see um yeah financial
wellness group
welcome yeah okay super so
um thank you for inviting me to
contribute to the discussions today
on the economic reset and recovery plan
for trafford i'm deborah ware
chief operating officer and i thought it
might be helpful to cover
um three questions i suppose one
is who are the financial wellness group
uh the impact of
the debt advice on the economy and the
challenges and opportunities created as
a result
of the pandemic so who are we um
the financial wellness group and the
companies that sit beneath it primarily
support people in financial
difficulty we started out in
1993 in a small office in broad heath
uh outgrowing that and moving to offices
at mansion house in
brooklyn in sale and since 2013 we've
been
snuggly nestled between kellogg's and
adidas
at trafford park so trafford is very
much our home and has been
for nearly 30 years um chris talks about
his purpose ours is to support people
nationwide who find themselves in
financial difficulty
to live more and stress less and support
them back
to financial wellness the financial
wellness groups authorised by the
financial conduct
authority to provide free debt advice
and subsequently offer
where appropriate the administration of
debt solutions
we offer all debt solutions available
within the uk and our services
accessible either online or by phone
but we also go wider than debt solutions
offering a more holistic approach to
financial wellness
providing additional free support in
maximizing people's income for example
offering discounts at most supermarkets
complementary benefit assessments there
was over 14 million
that was unclaimed in benefits last year
online doctors service and online
counselling
which really supports our customers who
are all in financially vulnerable
situations
with 30 of our customers having
additional vulnerabilities over and
above their financial situation
usually in the form of mental health
issues or age-related illnesses
so the doctors online doctors and
counselling service really lend
themselves
to supporting our customers which leads
me on to
uh the impact of covid on death advice
provision
i think a point made by council williams
in your february meeting was that until
furlough
another government aid falls away we
won't know the true
impact of the pandemic and i'd
definitely agree with him
for example we have seen a reduction for
the need in debt advice and solutions
since the first lockdown
however the expectation is that this
demand will return
in record volumes in the latter half of
this year
and in recognition of this we have
received funding from the money and
pension service to recruit and train
a number of additional debt advisors
this expected increase in demand for
debt advice
uh was also noted by the financial
conduct authority in their recently
released financial life
survey which stated that pre-covered
11 million people in the uk had low or
no
financial resilience meaning that they
weren't able to deal with
any income shocks that came their way
as you would expect this number has
increased to over 40 million that's a
quarter of uk
adults as of the end of 2020
and they also estimate that just shy of
seven million
more than double the number uh estimated
a couple of years ago are likely to need
debt advice by the end of this year
so i think against this backdrop i think
it's important that trafford
council looks to support
the key part of the economic recoveries
and ensuring that residents and
employees
can access good quality free debt advice
and support at the knee at the point of
need
especially pertinent given the lockdown
closure of many
face-to-face advice services across the
uk
and also within trafford
further we also know that one in three
businesses will be making redundancies
this year
we have been working with employers to
deliver redundancy support and advice
to specifically support those employees
whose roles have been lost
to covid
i think this leads me now on to the my
final slide which
notes the challenges and opportunities
created as a result of the pandemic and
i believe this can be broken down into
the four bullets that i've put there on
the slide
returns to work job creation debt advice
apprenticeship scheme
and uh the work that we're doing under
the financial wellness group
foundation as employers of over
350 colleagues we have been very
conscious
in supporting our colleagues through
what has been the strangest year
we're able to mobilize within a week of
lockdown
and to working from home which ensured
that our vital services were able to
continue to be provided without
interruption
that was the easier part i think the
more challenging part is going to be the
return to to
work uh current considerations relate to
um transportation offices
what requirement of office space is
needed now we are to work more flexibly
and how that additional office space
created can work differently for us
um it will as as chris talked about
the uh it will be interesting to see how
it matures i think
um a lot of talk around
creating flexibility working two days
three days from home
um it will be it'd be interesting to see
whether this will work
long term or whether over time we will
actually migrate back to that
working from office space in the same
way we did pre-covered
we are at the end of the day social
animals as chris noted
i've already mentioned that we have
recruited a number of additional debt
advisors already in october 2020 and
we're also recruiting for a number of
roles within our technology department
most businesses have created if they
haven't got one already
pre-covered a technology roadmap to
enhance their online presence in the
wake of covid
and when surveying our customers the
types of roles that we were seeing being
lost
through redundancy were as you would
expect relating to retail and
hospitality
whereas like i say debt advice and
technology i think are areas in which we
expect to see growth and therefore
retraining opportunities i think
specifically within trafford need to
focus on on those
types of roles we have just developed a
debt advice apprenticeship with the
institute of apprenticeships and
expect to start our first advisor
trainees imminently
i think it's worth noting that we are
able to support small debt advice
agencies with funding from the debt
advice levy
for their trainees on request so this
may support the trafford partnership
initiative spoke about
um in in your february meeting
and finally financial wellness group are
passionate about creating opportunities
for young people both through the
apprenticeships and our new initiative
partnering our foundation with the young
money charity
to deliver financial education to pupils
at
three secondary schools across trafford
including
sale high school and well acre which
also
again gives an opportunity for our
colleagues to utilize their volunteer
days
in supporting the charity and the
delivery of this education and again
this may create another way in which we
could in the future
look to to partner and support trafford
council
with more focus on that social value
as one of the larger employees in
trafford we welcome the opportunity to
speak to the committee today
and i would be happy to provide any
supplementary information
uh as if if required thank you
thank you very much deborah um i think i
think your group will be
a vital organization in in in
any recovery um plan that
that we have nothing working with you
and together um you know
that that would be superb and i think
um the range of
advice and help and support
uh job creation and
apprenticeship schemes you know all
you know to take the boxes
in in terms of um you know how we move
forward and
you know post covert
thank you so much for that and um
we've just got i think one more speak
and then we will open it all up
for questions but thank you so much for
coming along
much appreciated um
okay um richard i think
we've got enterprise you uh michael
and hillary uh i don't know
to speak yeah yeah we're on and
michael's going to share the
presentation with you
um so first of all thank you so much for
allowing us to present
my name's hilary chantalliga i'm sorry
my surname is so
unpronounceable but it was a good
attempt david
it was terrible
that's why i said michael and hillary i
know it's much easier don't worry about
them
don't worry um i'm the growth and
startup lead at the the
business growth hub the growth company
um and also the lead
on the enterprising you program and
michael
is the enterprising you engagement
officer so we're going to do a little
bit of a joint presentation
um michael's in charge of the pr um the
slides um so
i was just going to start by positioning
this for you and
for those of you who don't know much
about enterprising you
um it goes back to um
2019 when we um
successfully uh put a bid in for some
uh dfe money that had come through
as a pilot programme for um greater
manchester only so
a huge win for our area i think um
and we were really really proud to be
able to
deliver this um the growth company uh
is um jointly delivering this with
people plus
um and it is uh solely for the greater
manchester
um area it's very much a test and learn
because it's never been done before in
any part
of the uk um so very very exciting we've
got some exciting things
to tell you of how well it's progressed
so far so
michael's just going to tell you a bit
about the program itself and then i'll
come back in
and give you some stats
thank you hillary and good evening
everyone thank you so much for the
invite to come and see a few words so
what is
enterprising you then so anyone who
signs up to enterprising you will
receive
around about six months support and we
say around about six months support
because as hillary said it is a test and
learn pilot so we do have examples of
some people
who have had extensions on program
for a few months over the six months
mainly due to covert and
needing that extra support from
enterprising you
for the six months that um i saw that
they are with us they will have support
from a coach we have around about 15
and we've just advertised for some more
now the courses that we have
are fantastic they have either had a
business themselves in the past
so really understand the highs and lows
that come with being a business owner
or they coached businesses and can offer
expertise on
and often when when someone is
self-employed they can't see
um themselves so having someone there to
say
have you thought about this have you
tried that can really really be
important when you are self-employed we
also have
mentors on the program i believe we've
got around about 70.
now these aren't people who are employed
by enterprising you these
are um greater manchester businesses and
volunteers who are giving something back
to their
local area and often they are sector
specific so they really want to give
something back to startups
who are um new to the self-employment
game
and um can really benefit from expertise
from someone who's been there and done
that and got the t-shirt
we also offer support from a finance and
health and well-being specialist
as you can imagine over the last year
and
the referrals for both of these
specialists have been
on the increase and they've been
inundated uh but the good news story
is that i've come out with this have
been absolutely fantastic
on the finance side um that is the
person's personal finances so i'm not
their business finances
and however um shaheen who is the
finance specialist has some great
knowledge on grants
and um things that people can access
that they may not be
aware of um for some people they
and they may have a great little
business on the go but behind the scenes
they may be
funding that business via something like
a credit card for example
obviously that is not sustainable so
shaheen can look at that person's
finances and we've got a lot of examples
where he saved
um people thousands of pounds which then
they can then put back into the business
and help their business grow health and
well-being well we all know
obviously the stresses that we've all
had over the last year or so
my other half is self-employed and
arnold are getting a good night's sleep
eating well looking after your mental
well-being um
and in general really falls down the
pecking order so
having that one-to-one um contact with
someone who isn't involved in your
day-to-day
and just to offer advice and tips has
been invaluable for a lot of the
businesses
on enterprising next one on the list is
24 7 access to a digital and
um employee platform so
most of us in mainstream employment have
have um
things that we can access from our
employers and that offer a whole host of
benefits but self-employed people don't
so as part of enterprising you we offer
access to a digital platform
for completely free and that is
absolutely fantastic
for people who have never had that kind
of support before
uh so the next one we've got planned
access for 50
diverse co-working sites across greater
manchester now it does say planned
because we haven't been able to offer
this
um over the last 12 months because of
covert 19.
but in theory and in principle the way
it works is that we will offer
co-working sites for everyone on
enterprising you
these sites might be um high-tech spaces
in manchester city center it could be a
local library for example
and what they get out of that co-working
space is entirely up to them
it could be just to get them out the
house and we all know how much we all
want to get out of the house at the
moment
or it could be to grow that customer
base or to make
mainstream employment but have never
applied for a job before they may have
never
had to have a saving in their life and
have never um attended an interview
well obviously that can be quite scary
so we do have national career services
as well who can offer advice on all of
that um
and we would still say that as a
positive outcome because self-employment
isn't right for everyone
last on the list is fully funded
training and personal development
and we currently have around about 160
um
plus offers on there i think that's
actually increased since since i put
this slide on
and i'm going to touch on that in the
next slide
so the training and personal development
so this is training that is not
delivered by enterprising you we've
invited
sector specialists consultants
universities colleges and training
i think um michael's um yeah
just frozen so um i'll just take over
whilst uh hopefully he gets that back on
and it might be best if um if he goes
off video because sometimes
that makes um a difference um
so we'll um hopefully he'll interrupt me
um just see michael are you back on is
that
is that better can you hear yeah me
and so speaking of technology it's meant
to make our lives easier yeah but often
that isn't the case
and so yeah so this is just a snapshot
of the kind of offers that we have on
enterprise and use so these are
delivered by
sector specialists and training
providers so you can see on there
there's things around accountancy
so for someone who self-employed them
they might be great at what they do but
accountancy might
um scare the living life out of them
we've got leadership and management
web um web and project management
digital marketing strategy and planning
there's all sorts of things on there
there's even level three in dog walking
i didn't even know that was that was a
thing
but for someone who does that who is a
dog walker that might be the difference
between them
them opening up their customer base and
being able to potentially charge more
for the kind of work that they do and so
yeah really fantastic and it's an
open-ended framework so we are
constantly looking out for more to join
the framework so if anyone in your
network
would like to come on board they will be
more than welcome to apply to
so who is eligible for enterprising you
then so the first thing to mention is
it's not sector specific
so it doesn't matter what that person
does as long as it's legal then they
will be eligible for enterprising you
and the um the the participants must be
a resident of greater manchester
and they must have been trading for a
minimum of four months now
that has just recently changed it was
previously six months so that's a
fantastic addition
to the eligibility because it means that
a lot more people are eligible now
and for someone starting a business
enterprising you is now within their
reach
and the participants must be
self-employed um and that
basically means that they're in charge
of paying their own taxes
but they might identify as a sole trader
a limited company
a social enterprise uh freelancer etc
and last but not least on that list the
participants must not earn above
uh 27 000 pounds per year after expenses
now that does take into account their
complete income
so if that person in visit is in receipt
of benefits for example
we will take that in into account and uh
if that
person has a second income uh which
obviously we've seen a lot of
during carbon 19 then we will also take
that into account as well
we do have 10 access on that so if
someone
is um in free fall and their business is
in free fall but they have
um more than 27 000 pounds we can put a
business cares forward for why they
should
receive support from enterprising
thanks that's my bit now so when the
program has been running just over a
year
um unfortunately we launched and went
straight
into lockdown which is uh never an easy
easy thing for a new programme
but we soldiered on um but we've had
absolutely
um fantastic results so we've got nearly
a thousand clients um
started on programme already um which is
a great result
um but i just wanted to feedback some of
the
um stats that are coming out
particularly
um on trafford businesses because things
have been going exceptionally well
in the trafford area so in terms of
satisfaction um with the service we're
getting 100
um you know fully satisfied
um and exceeded um their expectations
everyone has been finding it a positive
um
experience but more importantly and this
is what the program's all about
it's about um increasing people's
um confidence their skills
and making them feel better about their
business and how they run it
and also how they cope with it in in
these
very testing times and
surprisingly given the doom and gloom
that's been coming out um
financially particularly about this
sector because this is hard for this
sector
um you know they aren't uh shored up by
massive profit margins and things like
that um
we are the lower lower end of the
self-employed
we've seen um really really good
um financial implications
particularly in trafford so just to give
you an idea in terms of
um increasing income
um trafford is one of the highest areas
um and also on the
increase in profit margin which is
really good so we've seen
things like increase overall of profit
of um
of inc income of over half a million
pounds well when you're talking of
people only earning um less than 27 000
that's
a really good result and particularly as
i say in this uh climate
we've seen in incredible um results on
the profit margins
as well um and also turnover so overall
turnover
increase across gm has been well over
two million
um pounds worth so um
our our kind of targets if you like for
increasing
um people's financial um
aspect have um have gone through the
roof so
really really pleased and i think one of
the things as i
have to mention is um which is
particularly pertinent because i always
when i
i kind of started setting up this
program i wanted it to be that warm hug
of support i really wanted it to help
people
not only do well but feel better about
themselves
feel better about their home lives feel
better about
what they're doing on a day-to-day basis
and that 94
increase in personal well-being is
really
really important um and uh
and it's it stands in its stead with the
um
with what michael's been saying about
the business coaches and how
um how caring and uh skilled they are
about helping their clients
all the add-on support things like the
employee
um digital platform
they can access health and well-being
support through that
from dietary to
exercise to how you're feeling etc
so the results speak for themselves and
um as i say
um i'm not just saying that because
we're on a trafford meeting but the
increase in trafford has been
exceptionally good
um so in most of them you're either
top or um in the top three so
of all the local authorities so uh i
hope that's encouraging
so we just got one more slide before we
go to questions and that's just so
you've got information should you want
to pick this up after this
meeting so so those are our contact
details but please do have a look on the
website because you'll see lots of
information on blogs
and case studies and things like that so
it'll give you a much better rounded
view of enterprising you
and thank you for your time thank you
very much
michael and hillary i think
what you are providing it seems that
it's going to be absolutely crucial as
we come out and under recovering
um and i think uh
i didn't know a great deal about your
organization but i feel i know
a lot more now and what what you are
providing
is something that uh you know i i
i think it's absolutely vital
in in that recovery plan and
any anything that can get 100
extremely satisfied doing well
so you you must be working really hard
and
uh do it doing a great job but thank you
for that now i need to
open this out for uh questions and we've
got a few in the chat um first one
up is uh councillor barry winston
he then there's councillor john mum and
counselor
aidan williams so
barry
thanks to the speakers that was
fascinating absolutely fascinating
and the um uh the first question goes to
is it is it chris from brumwood yeah
chris
i was really interested to hear
the uh the optimism around office space
because it it's kind of reinforced
something which
can't kind of a casual conclusion i've
come to
is that while people are talking about
working from home in fact
um you're always going to need the
officers and i see this myriad of my
um uh all my friends and neighbors
indeed family with the way they're
working now
they're working like three days a week
at home and two days in the office so i
think the need for office place is
always going to be there
also the intriguing thing is that the
need for the ancillary services around
there so the restaurants and the
takeaways
is actually i've seen that increase
locally because my neighbors who work
from home
whereas they would normally take a pack
lunch into the office and i'll get an
uber eats delivered during the day
because
they're not paying out on uh they're not
paying out on commuting
they're saving money that way that's
fascinating i feel very optimistic about
that
my my question is really around
manufacturing i spent much of the
2000s working on trans europeans
intra-european supply chains
where we er ev everything became
consolidated manufacturing was
put in certain countries and
because of the free market we literally
saved hundreds of millions of dollars in
the supply chain
which gives me um because of
brexit coupled with code and not very
optimistic view of manufacturing
returning into anywhere in the uk never
mind greater manchester but
you're quite optimistic about that so
i'd like to allow the the first question
is to you is to
maybe a bit more um uh detail behind
that as to why we should be optimistic
and i hope i hope we can be optimistic
should we ask the second question now
dave or should i wait till chris has
answered that question
yeah um yeah i i i think
if you if you haven't asked them all and
then
you know all the questions you have we
we need to keep them
snappy and uh you know both requests
both the questions on the second
question
and the answers yeah the um
the second question is to deborah oh
well yeah
okay then we'll we'll let chris um
answer that quick question first
chris hi can you hear me yeah
yeah i think um
why am i optimistic i'm optimistic
partly for
for negative reasons uh which is a
strange thing to say
um but i think without a doubt
the what this um
pandemic has done has probably reversed
globalization to a degree
in a way that we never thought it would
happen i think countries
views on risk around supply line
integrity
and security um are
are probably is well significantly
higher than if you believe the
press today the latest of the
pronouncement on vaccine
um manufacturing out of europe in terms
of
um basically preventing and taking
control of
a vaccine supply a meter threat and i'm
not sure it won't happen but
i think there's a degree of that and i
certainly think around certain core
skills
i also think that um we've got some
really really
um strong i'm going to talk now in the
northwest context
um some really strong areas where we're
producing some really really world-class
initiatives around research so
particularly advanced materials
um and in the life sciences
um sector um and i think there is
um government's good will and strength
and
desire to see us bring some of that back
on shore in terms of
manufacturing and production um i think
that there's um a massive
retraining and skills retraining that
we're going to need
post um coverage because i think there
are certain sectors where they're just
not going to employ the levels of people
they um they employed before um
but primarily i just think that we've
got we've got the skills
um in terms of what we're producing um
we've got a lot of the strengths that
the region needs in terms of
connectivity
um and the land to be able to deliver it
on
and close to where people want to live
and close to distribution hubs
um and i think that i think it's i think
personally i think um that this has been
a bit of a wake-up call
in terms of um if you think about we've
relied
increasingly on um just in time delivery
mechanisms
um both internally and from external
sources
um and we saw that fall apart um
and so i think it's been a real wake-up
call so i think it's
it's partly because of opportunity in
terms of quality skills and talent and
research
partly i think it's as absolutely should
be a national priority in terms of
a defensive measure going forward as
well
okay your second question thank you for
the answer chris
thank you that was fascinating the bit
i've missed was on the um
the kind of defensive thing in terms of
locally sorry dave i said i'd be quick
didn't i
yeah suppose a question to deborah it's
around deck counseling
the um the fact that there's
14 million people who have no no um
uh what's the word insurance against
income shock
and if you've got people who have no
reserves and who have a benefit system
is going to make them wait however long
you have to wait for benefits how can
you
death counsel them when they've got
there's nothing they can do
to because they have no reserves to pay
off their debt i was just curious
thank you they didn't have any
disposable income at all yeah exactly
if they don't have any disposable income
at all i think you're looking at
different solutions for example a debt
relief order
where there is uh that right off there
for people is it's basically a cheaper
version of bankruptcy
so rather than have the the large amount
of
fees that you pay to make yourself
bankrupt which runs into
hundreds of hundreds of pounds the debt
relief order is
90 pounds to basically look to
um to become uh to write off your debt
so there's
there's many different debt solutions
available to people depending on their
given circumstances
thank you
i finished dave you asked me to be quick
and i was
only the dog just crapped up on me
i apologize for that
that doesn't happen that didn't happen
when we were in the town oh david did it
i know but it's more fun isn't it
yeah uh right uh councillor john lamb
yeah thanks uh thanks david um
my question is around uh sort of you
know collaborative
working so when i was listening to uh to
chris deborah
and uh and michael the one thing that
struck me was that there appeared to be
some sort of overlaps
um and there was one around
accommodation i think
and there was one around you know debt
financial uh management and hillary of
course was making the
uh the points as well so i was
interested to know
um is there a mechanism by which
you know you you folks sort of come
together to
explore uh possibilities for
uh collaboration there may well be and i
may be missing
uh the obvious but um uh i wonder
whether everyone wants to comment on
that yeah so we're um we're in
uh many talks with the guys over at
bruntwood um
myself and heather have almost what
seems to be weekly catch-ups
um and we are very much engaged with
them with looking at co-working space so
um yeah we work um very closely with
bruntwood um
and i think um from from our point of
view on enterprising you from the
finance option
is that um it's very much that overview
and should they need
more um support then there are
the other um providers out there that we
would refer to
and we do refer um clients through
to those other support areas that's um
one of our
um you know key points that we don't
kind of hog them we do
make sure that we do join up and but
getting people to talk about their
personal finances is sometimes quite
hard but when they meet a business coach
they just burden which always say
um so that is probably the first time
they might have actually admitted that
they have got a concern
or an issue but yeah we do actually all
collaborate quite closely
um and one of my other programmes
um so got four contracts that i run
um we are um working
with heather over at bruntwood to have
that program delivered out of the one of
the bruntwood workspaces so
uh hopefully in just over a week i'm
going out to see the new
um new place on market street
um so that we can look at how that's
going to be managed and
how that's going to run that's from our
point of view
uh the growth company and with obviously
enterprising you
i'd probably just like to add there i
think um
it's been really interesting to hear
about enterprising
um enterprising you and i think that's
definitely something that i'm going to
take away because i think
we do get to speak to quite a lot of
self-employed individuals very much like
hillary said that are
recognizing the fact that they're in
financial difficulty and will need
support
and it's also under you know we signpost
a lot to
to where additional support is available
whether that be
charities or mental health dementia
samaritan's mind etc
and i also think that for those people
that are uh running their own businesses
to have that sort of support that is
offered there i think that's a really
interesting
um area that we could look to to
highlight and and refer people over to
to support them on that side of running
the business so i think it's been very
interesting to hear what you have to
what you guys had to say
yeah i mean i think i think the only
thing i'd add to um
to hillary and deborah's uh point is
yeah absolutely because the whole point
is we're trying to
create a place where that you've got new
businesses starting up where
where you you know we're trying to you
know improve and move skills forward
absolutely
we've got a role to play in that and
working together um
i think in terms of the new business um
piece i think where we can get even
better
is that crop it sounds very commercial
and crude but that cross-selling benefit
of
um you know you know people
understanding our customer base better
and
and and other people on this call and so
that we can help people navigate around
that whole ecosystem
so that they they see the value of their
business working with their business
collaboratively and their business
winning business from them
but then getting business back that
whole reciprocal that whole
reciprocal thing um i think we can and
kobe's made up really difficult
you know that developed the virtual
environment but but there's a there's
more we can do there and
really start to sort of you know to to
feed to feed the machine and make it
you know and make it much more sort of
self-serving in terms of the growth
for the for the area
yeah i mean i think i think it's uh it's
a really good question
and i think some good answers and
i think the more that we can all work
together
it's not always easy to do that and you
know
areas of work and so on and so on and so
on um
but but obviously we we have come
together i think
the nation with covet
and i think we need to come together for
the recovery so i think i think
it's vital that we do what we can
um hence this meeting tonight i think
yeah absolutely
which is really good um got councillor
aidan
williams then councillor newgross uh
aidan thanks chad and
thanks as well to to all of the speakers
that i agree with them
well barry had to say earlier it's been
interesting
hearing that tone of optimism from
vlogwood really it wasn't
um quite the tone i was expecting but i
would say as a stratford resident
um it fills me uh with my own sense of
optimism particularly given that um
the regeneration struck the town center
now finally
looks to be a the wheels are finally
turning on that project
um similarly it was really interesting
hearing from
the financial wellness we've been
enterprising you and i suppose i'm a bit
embarrassed
really that i wasn't already aware about
the really valuable work that they're
doing
in the bowler um but the the stuff you
said about
going into schools i think is so
valuable you know there's going to be a
generation of young people who are
entering um
an employment market now they're going
to find it more difficult
than i think well than any of any
previous generations have known in
decades
so being able to have start those
conversations
about your finances early and
understanding
really importantly that you know if
something does go wrong and you do find
yourself in hot water
the best thing you can do is get help
early on i think if you can instill that
message from a young age i think
that's really valuable and i i'd love to
see um
was in a position where that was a much
more routine practice of people going
into
schools to spread that message um
well reflecting on the fact that i
wasn't really aware of
the work of enterprise in you and the
financial wellness group
it does make me wonder whether or not we
as a local authority have
uh have more of a role to do and at
least promoting
the work of these organizations and i
suppose maybe this is one for
the executive member to take away and
maybe raise as well with
council of rocks um i did make a point
during the presentations of having a
look on our own website
and also that of the traffic partnership
and
i have to say one thing that struck me
was that actually the offer around
welfare
rights around debt advice um
you know and around money advice there
isn't actually much information on our
website and i do wonder
you know unless you're in the know how
easy it is to access information
about where to turn to you know hillary
said that you know
getting people to talk about the
finances is is actually really quite
difficult
because i think there's still a level of
shame for a lot of people and then
the other thing that i suppose i reflect
on is that
you know traffic's a it's quite an
affluent bother really but
uh the impact of the pandemic and the
lockdown
i think we're gonna see people who've
never really experienced financial
hardship
you've always had pretty secure
employment
start to experience um financial
hardship and distress in a way that
they've just never known
so else being able to promote services i
think is really important so i don't
know
counselor theme and maybe and that's a
little piece of work that we can look at
doing
just so that we're signed posting more
effectively and that we're letting
people know about the services that do
exist out there
and that's all i wanted to say really
thank you
thanks very much for that question now
councillor freeman
who's the executive member uh yeah
thank you thank you chen i think that
councilor williams does make some very
valid points there
um i first came across enterprising you
because they ran a webinar for all
councils in greater manchester
and that was a recent webinar that you
ran um
and i've since shared that webinar and
i've still got
and i'm prepared to share that webinar
uh council williams
right across all councils i've got the
the the
i was sent a copy of it and i will i
will send that out this week because
i wanted to hold back until we'd had
scrutiny because i knew that they were
coming to scrutiny
but i've shared a couple with councillor
acton and i will now share that with all
councillors
right across traffic so they're aware of
enterprising you
and similarly on debt advice if deborah
wants to send to me
any information that will promote your
organization i will ensure that is also
circulated to all councillors across
trafford
thank you very much yeah thank you
that's much appreciated and just to let
you know
michael um has regular meetings with all
the local authorities
um the the various teams within there so
uh that that's um you know an ongoing
and
uh also um sends out regular newsletters
so
it might just not have trickled down to
you guys which is a shame
um hence is uh running the
webinar for all the counsellors um the
other day because we realized that it
wasn't getting through to everybody
and that's one of the things that we
found really difficult during covid
because normally we would be out there
we'd be in the town hall
uh doors open come and talk to us you
know
um and kind of moving that to a totally
digital world has been tricky um
but we've uh we've done our best to get
the you know the word out there
and uh hence the you know impressive
number of starts on programme
um but yes there's always more that that
can be done so we would be ever so
grateful
for whatever you can share and support
us through that so thank you
okay thank you and thanks mike
councillor new gross um thank you
i think this is the last question we
will have to move on
after this thank you chair um can i just
apologize uh for not putting my video on
i'm low on bandwidth here
uh and i have to wear a covered mask so
i'm a bit muffled so thank you for the
three presentations they were incredibly
interesting
and there's a lot of them taking away
from those but each of you did touch on
the office requirements the social
requirements of
future work and i'm just wondering if i
can get a
brief view from all three seeing as
every one of you has
office needs and and foresees office use
what you might think the office
requirements
uh might be different in uh
post and pre-covered um i mean
you mentioned two or three day working
which would be
a two or three day reduction in office
requirements so
what's their what's your professional
view on that
can we have a quick answer from all of
you
if if that's okay because i i will have
to do one
i think from my point of view it's going
to be flexibility
so um yes we it might be less in terms
of days hours and
months but i think more people will be
accessing
because of the loneliness the um
you know the lack of collaboration
opportunities
so i think um office facilities are
going to have to be a heck of a lot more
flexible
that's my point of view
um i i totally agree with the
flexibility i think one of the massive
things
that it will achieve um is that
um what we define as the even if people
are in four or five days a week what we
define as the working day gonna change
and that's gonna have huge knock-on
impacts in a positive way or it ought to
employers respond to this in a positive
way around
sharing child care um you know the
drop-off pick up
all of those sorts of things um which
ought to make
um work you know the work working for
parents
um a lot easier um and a lot fairer
but it's also gonna have i think
significant knock-on impact on public
transport
so i think the you're not i don't think
we're gonna go back to that
half seven till nine madness i think
you're gonna see the rush hour
spread over earlier and later
both ends of the day and so we need to
think really carefully while
our response is to public transport in
that in that instance
and what's appropriate for you know what
was as a system
although it did didn't work but was
theoretically designed to cope with
those peak times
it now i think needs to respond to
become a system that needs to think
about something that works more
evenly and effectively across um the
whole day
that wasn't about the office sorry this
consequence apologies
no that's fine um and i think
you know as i mentioned we are looking
at
going back to work two to three days a
week offering that flexibility i do
think that the teams are wanting to come
in together so that
that continuation of camaraderie and
um and culture can still fester there
within
on the on the in the offices
um so we're going to just wait and see
how that works it might be the case that
more and more people over time
want to come back into the office i
would agree with chris i think
ultimately
will will we look just to actually
return to pre-covered
it's to be seen but i think at the
moment be
to rip the plaster off and expect
everyone to go back as they were before
that's not going to happen in our
organization i think it will be that
sort of half and half initially
see how that works and then and then
take a view probably
at the end of the year to see how we
want to to evolve
that working space
thank you right thanks for that
um and now we've come to
to to the end of this agenda item i'd
just like to thank
all our speakers chris deborah michael
and
hillary and i mean i i found it really
refreshing
and uh and i think um
from what i've heard tonight that there
is a
real desire to you know
collaborate and uh come together really
uh and i think encouraging
different organizations within trafford
um you know for really
a shared objective in in terms of
um you know the recovery that
we we need to make you know um big
because obviously
um you know there's huge challenges
that we face but i the the way that
you've all spoken is
really optimistic and i think that fills
me with a lot of
hope uh and i think we've
been a really good group together as
well you know and that that's
a big bonus as far as i'm concerned so
can i thank you all
so much i think we've we we've learned a
lot and
um i think this encourages those of the
council as well
you know to to develop um you know
reaching out of of all our businesses
and organizations and voluntary
organizations and pulling together
and so thank you again
you can stay for the rest of the meeting
but uh you you would probably prefer to
get off into the other room so
thanks again much appreciated thank you
for the invite thank you
thanks david thanks everyone thank you
enjoy the rest of the evening
bye yeah thank you thank you for having
me
no thank you chris
right so we'll now go on to um
item which one is it now
six which is the um acm
cladding and i did say um that i had a
question uh and it was from
um for peter cox
it was it's quite a difficult question
to read actually
can the meeting confirm why despite
being reassured by tht
um via t mcmahon
in a tenant meeting
it was 100 safe
white raw
in untreated polystyrene
insulation is currently
being removed from the totality
of all the ground floor walls of all
three timeless blocks
clubbing not included in the eighth
acm 15 it is still
a trafford council planning committee
approval fire proof
insulation material for tht or anyone
else
to continue to use as it must have been
in
2010
it's in three parts this and second part
is can
can the meeting provide government
documentary
evidence that approves any acm
cladding at all i've asked this question
for both kate green
the committee and have yet to receive
any answers at all
please include the acm cladding being
put
onto grafton court the statement that
tht
has completed a fire test is missing
the following hey did government carry
this test out
b when was it carried out see how much
did
tht pay for it
and the third part of it
um the question which applies to the
leader of the council sitting as a board
member of tht
and possibly having a conflict of
interest i think
i need to just sort of refer that to the
legal officers
to deal with um but i think i think
these questions um
can be passed on to tht
to either uh respond to it tonight or
through a letter um you know a written
response should i say
yeah i think probably if you can pass
that on to us if you haven't already
um we'll definitely put together yeah we
we we will certainly do that because it
it is
it's difficult to sort of cipher
without having it in front of you and uh
and then kate greenop obviously has
forwarded on her enquiries too
and we're formulating a response now
so we'll we'll now um go go on to
because that will be dealt with by
yourselves in in writing
once you get get it forwarded to you
um so so we we we have this series of
questions from mr stevenson uh who is
here with us tonight um uh
and uh i've said that he he could speak
but it might be
just where you you and the council
have uh answered
in writing um every question that
was asked i can't remember exactly how
many it was but it's quite quite a lot
and um and you put an answer in
in every box really um which we're
really grateful for um
and i don't know whether you want
to um you know highlight any
or just move into a discussion around
around them because obviously all
members have received
uh the questions and the answers um
i mean we also sent over a supplementary
update
um which i'll just probably put up a
third time points
for people yeah that would help
those being obviously all residents are
safe and there has been
throughout this process and plan of
engagement um
it's always been a two-way conversation
between us and our customers
in the towers it's never been an easy
conversation it's a difficult topic
to work through so you know we hold our
hands up and say we recognize the fact
that
it is a difficult situation and we can't
give everybody the only one straight
away but wherever they've
come forward with a reasonable and
understandable question we've obviously
done everything we can do to
to address the issue and provide the
necessary answers
um as as the council will know obviously
we commence this works in the
early summer late spring in 2019
we anticipated at that point that the
works would have been completed by now
um sadly obviously we've come across
some issues which have been exacerbated
by covid
which has resulted in the programme of
works being extended
i am pleased to tell you now that
princess and empress court will be
completed in july of this year
clifford is programmed for august and
then grafton
september and pickford in october
i'm quietly confident we can hit those
dates subject so there's not been any
further destruction
um i'm more than happy to take any any
questions that you yourself or
or any customers may have yeah i i think
at this
this point it might be worth asking
her will stevenson
whether he'd want to comment on
on some of the answers or the answers or
whatever
i have spoken to um will
um prior to the meeting so uh
and i did say would be able to speak and
and ask some questions um so
will for you are you i'm there can you
hear me
yeah i can hear you yeah i can't see you
if i can hear you
yeah i believe it's not working um
basically i'm happy with all of the
the answers that have been given um but
i do have
a couple of points where i could give it
a bit of clarification
um one of the main points for me is the
issue on the fire alarm system
uh especially within pickford court i
know that um
the trust has stated that there's been
11 callouts by great manchester fire
service two to five blocks in the last
12 months
but um in real terms for pickford court
in particular
there's been five times as many call
outs due to faults with that system
that great manchester fire services
attended than any other block and in
total it's more than all the other four
blocks put together
so i think there was a correspondence
not long ago stating that there was
going to be an upgrade to the fire alarm
system
but i haven't had anything since so just
like to ask
hopefully when that's going to be looked
at um because for me
his particular concern i'm a resident of
pickford court um another couple of
points
um basically at the scrutiny committee
meeting
um in january which was the last one
that um txt
attended there was a statement
about the great manchester fire service
advice stating that
um the cladding wasn't removed
immediately because the advice from
great manchester fire service was not to
remove the cladding
until you had a suitable replacement to
install um
but the problem i have with with this
information is this information then
went public
on the manchester union's website about
a week later stated
the comment from me and i think it was
that said that yeah we're not gonna we
were told not to take the cladding off
until we could replace it immediately
but at that point both empress and
princess course had had their bloody
fully removed
now not everybody has access to the
internet or had access to the scrutiny
committee meeting and wasn't fully
bursting
what was going on so for a resident in
particular empress of princess who's
reading this article thinking
well they're saying it's not to come off
but it's been taken off
now that everything's been off can you
trust confirm that we are actually safer
with the padding off now
than we were with the cladding on
because i found that a little bit
conflicting
the information that was given to what
was actually going on
um another issue for me in particular is
because i'm in pick up court we're gonna
be the last block to have it fully
replaced
um and in tune this year it's gonna be
the four years since grenfell
now i appreciate the fact that covert
has been
a massive issue for everybody and i
appreciate it's limited a lot of the
services that the trust could provide
along with the council and everybody
else but i think that
for a resident after grenfell it was it
was quite a it was quite a bad time
um we were told about the the waking
watching the fire wars and everything
which is it's been really really good
and i know they've ended now
but that's been a really good positive
steps by the trust
but from from my perspective and
perspective the other residents
it seems that every time we were updated
which was
to be honest prior to the scrutiny
committee last last year it was quite
scarce the information that we've given
um but it always seemed to be pushed
back pushed back pushed back and this
was prior
to anything that happened with kovid i
appreciate what's happened with covid
i appreciate it's had an effect on
everybody but
you know speaking for myself personally
i've up the majority of the kovit
knockdowns i've been in a block with the
acm cladding actually on it
i've also had a new baby in that time
during the middle of lockdown
so i have reached out to the trust i've
contacted and i've spoke to pete payton
i think it was last summer
um but i just feel
that the way that it's been done
has been false horizon after false
horizon and i i think really could do
with clarity on
the the issues i know there are
technical issues with the scaffold and
things like that i've been able to
procure it i know it was a difficulty
but the length of time the empress and
princess court have had this cladding
removed
will be i think probably nearly three
years coming up so when it will actually
be replaced
was there no option to perhaps remove
the scaffolding from them blocks whilst
the cladding was off
to reallocate it to the other blocks to
expediate the process
because we were told the issue was with
scaffolding and then the scaffolding's
been erected on three blocks and
samworth
all the while the scaffolding had been
on empress and princess for a number of
years
prior to it being installed here so i
think that
maybe the trust could provide
information as to was that possible was
it was it an option
um another couple of issues that i've
just gone through and let's say i'm
happy with the majority of everything
that has been said and i appreciate the
issues that have happened
um but for me and for a lot of other
residents
it's been a very very difficult time
especially during the pandemic because
you're talking about people who are
living in a tower block
who are literally told to stay at home
and we don't have gardens
you know we have a communal area but
you're not allowed to gather and things
like this
so people have been stuck in in these
blocks me in particular in a block with
this cladding on
for the majority of this lockdown and i
think that
i appreciate the fact that the trust has
improved and they have improved their
information that's given but
like i say again within this year we
were told what we were expecting
that the cladding would be removed in
august we're now told it's october
for my vlog in particular this has been
a constant thing that's happened
since we were first told about the
waking watch scheme um
i think the only other thing really i
wanted to address
was the heat retention in the buildings
now
i know that the the trust has said that
the majority of the building is not
affected it's only 15
that's actually had the cladding on but
in terms of real numbers for people in
flats in homes
that's 28 homes per block where their
external wall
their only external wall has had the
cladding removed now these are the one
bedroom
uh blocks directly above the entrances
and the exits to the three blocks on
tamworth
and like i said the entirety of one of
their walls has had the cladding removed
so going forward is the trust could the
trust contact these people to see
if it has had an adverse effect on their
heat retention and their their energy
cost because obviously in these times
people are counting the pennies um but
generally overall
i'm i'm quite happy with the majority of
the answers
but i i still feel i wouldn't say agreed
i think agrees a bit strongly but i do
feel
anxious um about the amount of time it's
taken
and the amount of false horizons that
we've had we've been told this is going
to happen it gets put back this is going
to happen it gets put back
are we likely to be faced with a
situation where these three blocks are
now going to have no cladding for the
next
three years because that's what we have
seen as residents
happen with the two blocks over at
empress and princess so i just want the
trust to
not lose focus on the point the fact
that in terms of
facts and figures the majority of the
buildings were not covered in the acm
planning it was only 15
but in terms of the actual residence
you know everybody has had to live with
this
and they shouldn't really have had to
live with it for this long
it's been coming up to four years and i
think that
whilst i welcomed the scrutiny process
and perhaps
i wasn't too concerned initially
with the process because i took
everything at his word and just assumed
it'd be ready to be ready
by the time my daughter came along last
may i had to bring her home to this to
this building
with the cladding on and i thought that
that was not going to be
the situation i thought this wedding was
going to be off it was going to be
replaced
so really i think i'm happy to meet with
the trust
to to discuss you know some of the
issues that i have i mean there's still
some things that i could do with clarity
on
but i think that it's important that
the trust does address the questions
that i've asked
because i think the majority of them are
valid you know i think that these
questions
do need to be answered you know some
people have lived in these blocks like
myself prior to the regeneration
which has been a very positive thing the
regeneration of the box has been really
positive the whole generation in the
area has been a really positive thing
but in this instance we're now faced
with the prospect of potentially having
sprinklers
installed in the buildings which is
going to be more disruption
uh to the residents because it's not
going to be a quick process
and then obviously we've got the
development of the new bolt street
development next door
which you know a lot of residents have
got questions on which
you know i know i'm part of the q a
session on that with traffic housing so
we
you know going forward i'll look at that
but i think that
it's important for the trust to to see
it from a personal perspective
um and i think that that has been missed
i think the opportunity to to engage on
a more personable level obviously the
pandemic
has had a massive influence on that
because the opportunity to have a
face-to-face meeting with people hasn't
been there
um for myself i've reached out
i've tried to to go through the proper
channels and address the issues that i
have
and i welcome the opportunity to be on
the scrutiny committee to raise these
issues
because they are important and i think
that they do need to be addressed
because
especially during the pandemic the
anxiety level has just increased
increased increase for everybody
regardless of where they live but even
more so for people who live in these
high-rise blocks
that's pretty much all the way to say
thanks very much for that
i think it is it's very useful to you
know
hear a view from someone who actually
lives
in in the high rise
can you try to
forgive me if i've missed some of them
obviously that was there was a number of
queries there
well could i first offer the opportunity
to yourself to join our high-rise living
panel
um uh yeah yeah i'd i'd be more than
happy to
participate in that yeah um pete's
obviously with us this evening pete will
be
in contact um okay we'll put you on that
panel and then your voice will be heard
you know by itself and by all the senior
people at tht
um i can i can hear him pick up the
distressing voice so
i think it's important that as a
landlord we recognize
the distress that customers want to go
through in this situation i think we'd
all
rather not be in this situation to start
with what we are
um we have tried to address some of your
questions
in terms of the the alarm system at your
tower
um i can give you the assurance right
now that we'll take it we're going to
take
a look at that if it's not already being
done so um it will be looked at
um and the the outcome of that that
review
will be shared with yourself and the
horizon panel we're going to try to be
as transparent
as possible um in terms of the time
taken to remove
just to clarify we took the cladding off
in
june 2019 the things when we started the
process
on princess and empress and
it has taken us longer to progress this
piece of work than we wanted to
we were hoping for anticipating a 12 to
18 month program initially
that's been extended because of the
issues that we've discovered
and obviously kevin has contributed to
that extension as well
um the trust was very aware of the fact
that the towers the first and second
town princess and memphis were taking
longer than anticipated on the back of
that
we held a meeting with the contractor
our principals and their principals got
together
and decided to accelerate the program
and by doing that we would change the
approach
so the initial approach is going to be
that would take off the old defective
cladding
correct the framing that's on the
existing towers place to
obviously replace the insulation and put
back the new panels
what we found obviously was it was
taking too long to process the work
by taking that approach um so on towers
three four and five we took the decision
to take the panels off
strip the frame put new frames on that's
how come we were able to accelerate the
program
and why it will take probably three or
four months less for the
towers
so there has been structured decisions
right the way along the process
but we must recognize that obviously it
wasn't as quick as what we would have
liked
but we have taken the steps um to
complete the program at the earliest
possible opportunities
so but well i i acknowledge the point
you're making uh we can only apologize
again for the time it's time to be taken
off
in regards to the heat retention issue
some of these questions obviously have
also been answered through
the response that the mpk was just gonna
excuse me it's gonna
provide and share with you guys but um
the trust
as of yet has not received an official
complaint about loss of heat however
that doesn't mean that we aren't open to
the idea that there could be
potential heat loss again i'm more than
happy to come sit with the high rise
living panel
and we can discuss actually a sensible
fair way in which we can address this
issue
um so for a couple of years to give us
uh some build-free
recording coming off and some bills now
we can look at what the losses or what
the difference is
and then we can put together an
appropriate compensation package for
yourself and everybody else is
who is affected by it so again the trust
is
is more than open and willing to address
any of any particular issue
now i think i've pretty much picked up
all the points unless i've missed any so
please fire alarm one yeah i think he
addressed that at the beginning
sorry about that yeah that that that's
fine
are you okay with that well yeah yeah
yeah i'm more than happy i'm
grateful for the opportunities that i
speak as well but i think um
you know the high-rise panel um
sounds like a good idea that you you
know you could be on there
um yeah so thanks very much for those
questions and and answers from
here thank you very much well it's it's
pete
so we'll catch up and we'll get an
invitation out to you
and we'll have a chat before yeah that's
fine yeah that's fine
yeah well thanks thanks very much i i
think
members particularly uh
are pleased that you've been able to
come along with
um and give that perspective and
ask those questions i know a number of
people have
met members of uh you know praise you
for
for the comments that you've made and
how how you've actually presented it
in you know real you know
good way um so
thanks for that we still have some
questions i think there's a question
from um counselor aidan
williams thanks sure
i suppose just first of all compliment
the point you've made yourself so i
think it's really welcome
development that we've been able to
facilitate
um this sort of discussion in a way
that's transparent and has involved
residents and i think that's really how
i see um scrutiny working
in the future and i'd love to see more
of it i suppose i don't think we've had
well i've certainly not in my time on
the committee have that sort of
experience so
i i just think this has been a positive
development all around and he had a
couple of quick questions
if it's okay um just on question 10
in the document and thank you for the
written response it's really
comprehensive
um there's a balcony fire referred to
um and i was just wondering um it sounds
as though
so the residents saying that they've had
to learn the fire warden themselves
would a balcony fire be um an event that
wouldn't be picked up
by the fire detection system itself and
taking it from that then
you do you want to take that question
yeah yeah happy to take that
aidan um yes at the moment
the the way the uh the regs look at it
is the balcony space is an
outside space so that that's the way the
the regulations see it so
at the moment there is no detection
within the balcony space because of
course i wasn't involved in the original
regen but i believe the balcony's
changed and there's a cover placed on
the outside
so we're looking to make sure we're kind
of looking at that to make sure that
if there is a an event and a balcony
that it doesn't travel to other
apartments
so that's that's on the that's on the
brief
at the moment aidan but yeah right now
um
there is no fire detection in a balcony
space because it's considerably
an outside space but we are separately
looking at the risk associated with
something going on fire there and seeing
that we can manage that
because strictly speaking of course the
balcony is a balcony
it's not a habitable space so strictly
speaking
there shouldn't be combustible items
and unless someone deliberately starts a
fire
then it shouldn't happen but what we're
looking at
as i say from a management point of view
and what we can do to design and
the compartmentation to make sure that
fire doesn't creep
from one balcony to another balcony
should should it happen in the future
and then
just um i think the response to question
11 you sort of talk about working
alongside gmf of us
and about um the the standard that
you've been found to adhere to i'm just
wondering in an earlier question is the
issue with them
retrofitting sprinklers raised and
i know in your response you said that
it's something that sort of is an
ongoing piece of work for consideration
do you
appreciate that i'm putting you on the
spot here and you know probably not
thinking
business decisions are just made at the
click of a finger do you have any sort
of impression for what sort of time
scale are you working to
when you'd have an idea of whether or
not it would be possible for
spring this to be retrofitted in the
blocks because i know gm frs are
particularly keen
to try and push for that to be done um
and these from presentations we've had
from them previously
so what we've done is we've started
consulting with customers about whether
there's an appetite for
sprinklers in their buildings and what
you'll find is that the appetite's not
that big or is that strong as what you
would have anticipated so we need to
take that into consideration
there is a large level of disruption
when we obviously in certain sprinklers
bear in that mind the trust still is in
a position where it's not fully decided
on what the approach is going to be
we're currently working on our five-year
asset management strategy
um which will factor in the cost of
sprinklers
so i can come back at a later date and
provide you with probably a confirmed
answer in the time frame
as to what will happen and when yeah
that would be appreciated thank you for
that
yeah yeah okay okay
[Music]
did counselor new crush did you want to
speak
or i was just
sending my thanks for uh the uh wilf uh
and uh his um
his contribution and thank you chair for
allowing it
yeah no no problem
okay i i i've just got one question
really and it is
question eight um and it was
where it was stated in 2020 that any
resident that had concerns
and obviously following grenfell
and wanted to be re-housed would be
given
the utmost priority the answer given
to today our agreed approach
was that if someone wanted rehousing
from high rise due to grenfell we would
give them
advice on routes to re-housing
that is a different emphasis as far as
i'm concerned from what i heard
um all that time ago in 2020
yeah obviously the situation has changed
all the cladding has been removed
there's fire alarms in place those
buildings they're having
uh level four fire risk assessments with
all of the actions have been completed
the high rise towers are a safe place to
live so
i think i think that that's a different
point in in
in in many many ways because obviously
there can be a trauma of
seeing something like that happen in the
high rise
flat um and
to change the emphasis i think
um they're kind of misleading really
because
[Music]
it is a change
so uh i fully understand the point that
you're making
in the in the aftermath of ground floor
the immediate aftermath there were a
number of requests that came through
we accommodated all of them where
weren't possible and there were people
moved away from or out of other towers
but obviously now as we return to a
position of normality where
the towers are a safe place to live um
we have a number of different pressures
on on people wanting to move for various
different reasons some of them are very
vulnerable some of them very difficult
situations
and they all must be given the
appropriate amount of consideration and
priority so it's difficult for me to
come here and say yes we will do it on
that basis
but if somebody has a serious issue and
they come forward with it it will
definitely be considered
okay thanks for that
um so there's no other questions
uh can i thank uh
ian and pete for
coming along uh to tonight it it is much
appreciated and
uh i know that you've been working
really hard
with the higher ed and i thank you for
the comprehensive answers that you've
given i also
again thank will for for coming along
tonight
and because you know that has been
extremely useful for
the members to hear that voice
um so so i'm sure that we'll
be meeting again at some point uh well
hopefully and we you know we'll keep
you know we'll keep the channels open
should i say um
obviously like i said before we will
attend whenever we're invited to do so
yeah my apologies if my child care issue
the last minute
no you you you've always said that and
you've always met that so
um yeah so thanks thanks very much
much appreciated um so
um we're coming to the end of our
meeting
anyway uh the the only other item that
we have is
urgent business and i don't have any
um so if anybody else has got anything
to say before i close the meeting
no i will thank you all very much and
as i always say have a safe journey into
the next room
so bye to you all
thank you thank you good night bye thank
you very much